Next, we have Vera, Cassandra,
Angela, Jennifer and Michelle.
(audience cheering)
Oh, I love, you guys look so beautiful!
Oh my gosh!
(audience cheering)
Oh my god, Chris Appleton,
give us a thought about these beautiful transformations.
Well, I think the key message to all of this is
is that everyone looks beautiful before and after,
we've established that,
but sometimes you just need a little help along the way.
Sometimes you just need someone to say, "I see something."
You know, by talking like, "What's your vibe?
What are you into?
What would you aspire to look like?
What outfits do you wear?"
All these little details.
Sometimes you just need a little bit of help to be like,
"This would really compliment you."
And it might be a subtle change, like a side bang.
Or a bigger change, like a color transformation.
It's not necessarily about cutting someone's hair off
or being wild with a transformation,
it's really just about channeling into
what that person wants
and how they wanna express themselves.
And then, complimenting the look.
Your hair, like with the beautiful fullness
in the front and on top
is just so beautiful and becoming.
You guys, you look amazing!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Okay, next, is Bill and Gina.
Come on out!
(audience cheering)
Wow.
Okay.
Gina, you look so beautiful.
And, Bill, you are literally throwing off
very different vibes in your picture.
Now your wife, Danielle, is in the audience
and she nominated you to be here today.
Danielle, thoughts?
I think he looks great.
I think he worked really hard during the pandemic
to bring a little normalcy to kids that didn't have it.
And I just think he really deserves this.
(audience clapping)
Bill, I'm sensing swagger, am I wrong?
No, I feel amazing.
I have to be honest with you.
These people are wizards.
I know, I think I made a joke
about my dead libido might have come back to life
through their tutelage.
I do, it's so funny and that's this empowerment
I am talking about.
And, Gina, I hear you're celebrating
your 40th year as a teacher!
Wow.
(audience cheering)
Will you give us, as if we're your students,
a little wisdom?
I think I'm just representing all teachers everywhere,
I feel like a regular person,
just so flattered to be here.
And kids are great, I have the best job in the world.
We can transform, we can change ourselves.
You are perfect already.
Yeah.
But if boosting your confidence
gives you that joy,
then do it.
Absolutely.
And we do need the experts.
I am not an expert in beauty, and fashion, and hair,
and yet I've been raised in an industry my entire life
that revolves around it,
and I still look to the experts.
Yeah.
So thank you, guys, truly.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Well, I am so happy to say that everyone is going home
with a flat iron from our company
that I have it's called Flower Hair.
And these tools, I'm very proud to say,
actually just launched and they're already sold out.
Oh, wow!
Woo-hoo!
Yes.
(audience clapping)
And I think
the reason that that might be,
and I'm interested in your take, is it's a mini.
Yeah.
And it's a travel
and it's small.
Listen, women want convenience.
They want it quick and easy.
And we don't have hours in the morning.
It's about quick, easy, simple hairstyles.
And I think that's why the mini is so popular.
Just because it's quick and easy,
you can travel with it, it's convenient.
They're not intimidated.
That's the same with my makeup.
It's like, how are you gonna make it
achievable for the real world?
Not that thing of like,
"Oh, only the Hollywood stars can look like that.
I could never do that."
It's like, no, quick, easy, simple,
and making sure that the product does all the work for you.
I appreciate you saying that.
(upbeat music)